this this this this is Doug demuro
Doug's built one of the best car
channels on YouTube and made videos that
have millions and millions of views and
he's leveraged that into a business that
every Creator dreams a building hoping
to connect with those enthusiasts though
whose own auction website he's funny
candid and he's worked incredibly hard
to realize his dreams Doug's story has
lessons for anyone who's been interested
in making cool content or even one day
starting their own company and today I'm
going to take you through the quirks and
features of this unique Creator who
broke all the rules and I promise you
even if you're not into cars you'll love
this
Doug's Journey began in his hometown of
Denver he was on a date and he saw his
dream car driving past a Porsche Carrera
GT yeah I was on my first date ever as a
child and no one believed me that I had
seen the car and so I started carrying
around a digital camera everywhere yeah
and that kind of started touched on
touch was like the Touchstone of the
whole thing seeing the Carrera GT
kick-started Doug's career as a car
spotter he loved it so much and got so
good at it that Automobile Magazine
wrote a profile about him in 2009 by
then Doug was living in Atlanta and
studying economics at Emory University
he already knew that he wanted to work
in the car industry after graduating and
that's precisely what he did after
college Doug got a job with Porsche in
North America as a vehicle allocation
manager making decisions about which
dealerships new cars were sent to at the
start he loved it he was working in his
dream industry and he got to drive a
Porsche 911 as a company car but pretty
soon Doug realized it wasn't all it was
cracked up to be I still remember I was
working on a cubicle I was working for
Porsche and that was cool but I was
working in a cubicle doing Excel
spreadsheets and you pick up your 6911
your seventh and you're like is this
going to be the whole my the Pinnacle of
my life and I just kind of realized I'm
23 I want to I want to try something
different the straw that broke the
camel's back came in December of 2012
when Doug had to go on a business trip
to Germany on his wife's birthday when
he got back to the states he gave his
notice for the first few weeks after
leaving Porsha Doug had no idea what to
do he wasn't Fielding tons of job offers
from other car makers but he did have
one thing he'd started writing for a car
website called AutoTrader it wasn't
anything special Mostly consumer focused
articles with titles like should you buy
at the end of your lease but it paid the
bills and Doug really liked it in early
2013 Doug went to the North American
Auto Show in Detroit and wrote about
what he saw he sent the piece to the
truth about cars a website which
specialized in snarky clever commentary
he didn't know them they didn't know him
it was a total shot in the dark but it
worked people loved it that piece made
Doug really start to believe in his own
writing he told himself if Top Gear
could be funny with cars why couldn't he
so he started writing regularly for the
truth about cars he wasn't getting paid
but he was honing his writing and
beginning to build an audience and soon
another opportunity came up eventually
uh Jalopnik came out with this thing in
the summer of 2013 where you could make
your own blog post one and it would do
okay and they'd maybe post another in
another and eventually they were like
okay this guy's pretty good and they
started to post a lot of my stuff
Jalopnik was a big breakthrough for Doug
not financially but it was by far the
biggest car blog on the internet there's
a lot of bad car writing out there done
by people who are just SEO hacking but
Doug was like a breath of fresh air his
articles were funny they had tons of
Personality they helped him build an
audience and one of Doug's readers was
about to change his life end of 2013
comes along and I get an email from a
reader and he says you should try you're
a very funny writer you should try
making videos the concept had never even
crossed my mind so Doug decided it was
time to make his first video he knew
that most people's First videos were
kind of crappy but he didn't want to do
that if he was going to make videos he
wanted them to be good straight away
Doug's first video was a farewell to his
Cadillac Station Wagon I spent a week
filming this video it's like six minutes
long I still remember I spent I spent
500 to rent props eventually that video
went up and actually it was pretty good
and I still watched that video today and
you can see yeah I would change this I
would change that but it's so terrible
from the very start Doug took a totally
different approach from other car
reviewers at the time most reviewers
just focused on how the car drove it
made for a pretty flat experience but
Doug was just so passionate about cars
and he had a knack for sharing that
enthusiasm in a really genuine and
relatable way but it was still an
incredibly long way from one Charming
Scrappy video to four and a half million
subscribers he needed a hook so I bought
a Ferrari 360. but now I have to get it
home the pro problem is the Ferrari is
located here the story of how Doug ended
up buying a secondhand Ferrari 360 is
pretty crazy he only had half the money
and no one wanted to lend money to a guy
who didn't have a job so his parents had
to co-sign the loan for the rest and
when he bought it he had to drive it
from Florida back home to Atlanta he was
taking a big risk but it paid off today
tons of people make videos featuring
exotic cars but back when Doug was
getting started he was the only YouTuber
with a Ferrari and Doug didn't just make
one video with the Ferrari he made
almost 20. he took it drag racing he
made videos about how challenging it was
to do things like run errands and get
gas he even led a bunch of his friends
in some strangers test drive it it was
an audacious strategy but it was
successful Doug's Ferrari videos got
hundreds of thousands of views and
helped establish his channel and yet
despite how much of a hassle it was for
him to make all of those videos let
alone buy the Ferrari in the first place
he still considered him a writer who was
just making videos on the side didn't
even think for a second that you could
make money on YouTube that I would do
this that this would be a thing I had
bought a Skyline GTR and a Hummer that
year to write about and I was looking at
the numbers for my articles and I was
like the Articles just aren't as popular
and then I still remember I clicked over
to my YouTube and the YouTube videos
were getting twice as many views as the
articles are three times I mean I was
like oh okay in fact he thought he'd
eventually get serious and go to law
school Doug moved to Philadelphia but
the channel was gaining momentum Doug
began to get an interesting thought
maybe this YouTube thing was legit but
he still had doubts back then not many
people were making a living from YouTube
and to make things even more complicated
new creators were making videos with
really exotic cars Doug knew that if he
didn't change up his strategy he'd be
left behind maybe he'd have to go back
to law school after all so he started
mixing it up he made a video where he
crushed a PT Cruiser with a Hummer
another video where he reviewed his
friend's Land Rover got almost 2 million
views Doug learned quickly that variety
was the key to keeping things fresh he
bought an Aston Martin V8 Vantage it
wasn't the most exciting car in the
world but I bought it because I was able
to get this car with an unlimited
mileage bumper to bumper warranty so
Doug figured there was scope to make
some cool content with it he took the
Aston Martin on an adventure and that
Adventure helped him realize something
truly important I drove my Aston Martin
across the country and back from
Philadelphia to California and back in
2016 and I hosted meetups and I remember
the Meetup I did a meet up in Boise
Idaho and I bought like from a grocery
store like 12 like a dozen cookies I was
like me and the four people who show up
will eat these things well like 50
people show up I was like uh oh because
the rest of the meetups I had scheduled
in big cities the biggest moment was for
me was in Minneapolis we showed up at
the site the cops kicked us out went to
a completely different side was just
ridiculous and still like hundreds of
people showed up the Oscar Meyer
Wienermobile showed up and that was the
night when I knew that I didn't have to
just worry about oh one day am I gonna
have to quit this and do some real job
just three years after quitting his real
job Doug was getting millions of views
on YouTube the Aston Martin provided him
with enough content to publish a book
and he was building a loyal audience of
people who loved his content it was a
really exciting time in the summer of
2016 autotrader.com asked Doug to be the
editor of their new oversteer blog in
hindsight it probably wasn't great value
for him Doug's videos were doing better
numbers than his articles and taking on
new responsibilities like managing
writers was kind of orthogonal to making
content but he just loved writing and
figured that editing a Blog would
provide him with more video ideas so he
said yes and around the same time he
also said yes to his first brand deal
now I've rented this geebly here in
Nashville Tennessee using a service
called turo which is this cool company
that's sort of like Airbnb for cars turo
has given me a budget to rent cars and I
decided to rent this one because turo
was really the best way to experience
the Ghibli on paper this looked like a
great fit partnering with turo let Doug
review a wider range of cars which he'd
already identified as the strategy to
keep growing his channel this deal was
what let him review the first generation
Tesla Model X which remains one of his
most popular videos to this day but it
was risky if you're a Creator whose
appeal is based on your knowledge and
Charisma then building trust with your
audience is crucial that trust takes
years to build but it's really easy to
lose Doug avoided that outcome by
continuing to make content you couldn't
find anywhere else as his channel got
more popular he was able to get his
hands on more interesting cars like the
Bugatti Chiron and the bizarre and
ancient BMW Isetta and he wouldn't just
read out their specs he'd go through
each and every Quirk and feature often
in great detail watching Doug's videos
would teach you things you'd never get
from just reading about a car in a
magazine and they were always
entertaining I think one of the reasons
my channel was successful is because I
was able to appeal to non-car
enthusiasts because of my format so I
have a video titled here's why the
Rolls-Royce Phantom is worth six hundred
thousand dollars you don't have to be
into cars to be like why the hell would
someone pay 600 000 and then you get in
there and you're seeing there's like
power operated curtains over the windows
and that is good content regardless of
like who you are and what you're
interested in Doug was perfecting the
art of making videos that piqued the
Curiosity of people who weren't really
into cars while still satisfying purists
and he was learning new ways to keep his
viewers engaged on a trip to New Jersey
Doug and his wife came up with the
concept of the Doug score basically the
Doug score judges a car in 10 separate
categories split across two separate
groups weekend which measures the car's
appeal to enthusiasts and daily which
focuses on the car's practicality the
Doug score is great not only did it give
Doug a way to compare all the different
cars he'd reviewed it gave his fans
something to argue about it's no
surprise that lots of people skip right
to the end of his videos just to see the
Doug score with a couple of new features
under his belt Doug knew it was time to
double down he started posting two
videos a week in December of 2016 he
made twenty thousand dollars he was
reviewing cool vehicles and getting his
subscribers to send in their own
interesting cars the flywheel had
started spinning and Doug was about to
get that mainstream recognition that
every car Enthusiast dreams of today
with Doug demuro and I'm Doug if you
don't know a big car guy he lives cars
he breathes cars are you ready to play
yeah let's do it all right put that on
this thing on this is the blindfold okay
I'm gonna turn you around here all right
this is great this is my first time in
Jay Leno's garage and I can't see
anything doing a video with Jay Leno was
a huge turning point for Doug it gave
him massive credibility while exposing
him to a new cohort car guys who weren't
on YouTube and it led directly to a
major Milestone this is one million
subscribers I released my first video
just over four years ago and I can't
believe I've reached a million
subscribers Doug had made it he'd become
the best car YouTuber around just by
being himself but he knew better than
anyone that YouTube was fickle sure he
was doing great for now but things could
change so quickly he built a big loyal
audience and now he started thinking
about how to use that audience to help
cure his family's future the ideas
started to form in early 19th spring of
19. YouTube was not going to work
forever someday the algorithm maybe
wouldn't you know you don't have much
control when you're a YouTuber and so it
hit me that like I gotta take the
audience and bring them somewhere that I
can do monetizing that I can turn into a
real business one of the perks of being
a popular YouTuber was that people would
often write to Doug asking to hang out
that came in handy whenever he moved to
a new city one day after Doug and his
wife had moved to California Doug got an
email from a guy named Blake Machado
Blake was an experienced software
entrepreneur who'd successfully raised
millions of dollars from Bessemer and
Google Ventures the two decided to grab
dinner and talk about business
opportunities Doug knew from personal
experience the people who loved cars
also loved buying and selling them and
he also knew that aside from bring a
trailer there weren't many places where
people could reliably buy and sell rare
cars so Doug and Blake decided to create
an online Marketplace for rare cars Doug
handled the strategy while Blake built
the site everything seemed to be going
great there was just one problem fast
breaking developments the coronavirus
pandemic spreads the number of cases
soaring 2020 is now the deadliest year
in U.S history it looked like the covet
pandemic was a terrible time to start an
online car auction website people
weren't out driving cars they were stuck
at home and they wouldn't spend money on
fancy cars they were worried about
losing their jobs but as it turned out
Doug was wrong the pandemic was actually
the perfect time to launch the US
government pumped trillions of dollars
of stimulus into the economy in order to
prevent a recession and interest rates
were on the floor so it was easy to get
financing actually we launched into the
greatest car market in the history of
the automobiles the economic conditions
helped cars and bids take off pretty
much right away since its launch it sold
almost a quarter of a billion dollars
worth of cars across more than ten
thousand auctions the site gets more
than a million users every month numbers
like that caught the attention of the
churning group an investment firm which
specializes in creator-led businesses
and in February of 2023 the churning
group paid 37 million dollars for a
majority stake in cars bids it was the
culmination of a journey that had
started with Doug getting paid 25 to
write blogs and ended with him getting
millions of dollars for building an
incredible business a business that was
only possible because of his massively
successful YouTube channel it's a
beautiful story and it's a fascinating
business case study Doug must have
really been paying attention in his
economics classes at Emory because he's
done a great job of applying some
fundamental principles to cars and bids
the first one is product Market fit or
the Creator equivalent you don't have to
change your videos to incorporate your
business or what you're selling that is
incredibly unique for the Creator space
there's a finance YouTuber named Graham
Stefan who has about as many subscribers
as Doug but Graham decided to start a
coffee company it never really made any
sense since he talks about business and
finance not coffee and he's only
mentioned it a couple times on his
channel compare that to What doug did he
spent years building trust by talking
about cars he then leveraged that trust
by building a business that lets people
buy and sell cars in his videos which
are about cars he promotes cars and bids
and he can review cars that are on the
website in order to generate more
interest in the auction there's almost
no marketing costs involved nothing
feels weird and it's all just perfectly
aligned if you watch my videos you're
probably familiar with the concept of
zero marginal costs it's fundamental to
software making one more copy of a
product basically costs nothing cars and
bids works on the same principle there's
no incremental cost to the website for
listing another car it's all just
software code that runs continuously and
for the same reason expanding to markets
beyond the United States will be really
cheap all they need to do is translate
the website and in fact every new car
that's on the site gives people more
reasons to visit the site so not only
are the marginal costs absolutely tiny
they're smaller than the marginal
benefit if you've been following the
Creator news you've probably seen that
Mr Beast might be shutting down Beast
Burger it's a really unfortunate
situation but it kind of makes sense
ghost kitchens are a risky business
model because there are so many links in
the chain you need the supply chains to
work properly the kitchen staff to cook
the food and the delivery staff to
actually deliver the food to the
customers not only do all of those need
to work but they all need to get paid
with cars and bids the value accrues
more directly to the company the
audience took years to cultivate and the
website costs money to build but now
that those pieces are in place the
company can capture all of the value
they don't have to pay other suppliers
to make the system work I meant Jerry
Seinfeld like a year ago and Jerry tells
me go watch all your videos and I'm like
uh uh do you like Porsches Doug's
talking about Jerry Seinfeld here next
to Jay Leno he's probably the most
famous car collector on Earth and if
Jerry Seinfeld goes and buys a car on
Cars and bids he will generate more
profit for Doug than a regular person
would the reason is a concept called
price discrimination let me explain
listing a car on Cars and bids is free
and the seller gets 100 of the sale
price but buyers pay a 4.5 commission up
to 4 500 so the more expensive the car
the more money cars and bids makes price
discrimination is really powerful
because it means you're able to extract
more money from your richer customers
it's the concept that underpins
microtransactions in gaming rather than
getting a flat 60 out of everyone
developers built a way to make more
money out of super fans most creators
only ever really scratch the surface of
price discrimination with things like
tiered subscriptions but Doug has
naturally built it into the core of cars
and bids so what can creators learn from
Doug that patience authenticity and
decency or virtues once you build an
audience you don't have to rush to
squeeze as much money out of them as
possible it's a long game wait for the
perfect pitch and then swing hard what
about non-creators what can they learn
honestly I think the main lesson here is
that cars and bids is a great way to
learn important business Concepts
compared to apple apple is the world's
biggest company but it took 50 years and
billions of dollars to become the
company that it is today you can't just
copy its formula for success but in his
own words Doug is just a guy you can
look at how he's built demand achieved
perfect product Market fit and leveraged
price discrimination and apply it to
your own situation I'm not saying it's
easy Doug says it's harder to get
started on YouTube today than 10 years
ago but if you have the knowledge the
passion and the work ethic you can do it
Doug dimiro is proof that sometimes the
good guys do Finish First he's never
been a ruthless business person he's
always just loved cars and he's found an
incredible way to share that passion
with other people his story is full of
inspiring lessons for creators and
non-creators alike and I can't wait to
see what he does next I love talking
about unique creators and what makes
them successful to learn why
billionaires love Mr Beast watch this
video next thanks a lot